moi je fais les plombs mais si c'est
parce que non même de la saison
compétitive
l'interview du tennis non très très
longtemps
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et bien voilà mes chers amis nous sommes
ici pour parler d'un mathématicien qui
est mort il ya cent ans alors on va
essayer d'abord de discuter un peu de ça
si vous voulez bien puis après on verra
comment on peut filmer ce n'est pas
évident je vous demander aux uns et aux
autres ce que vous pensez
la manière de procéder pour ce film qui
nous fait un peu peur
cédric voilà c'est compliqué parce que
poincaré on se le voient de plein de
plein plein de prisme différent plein de
facettes différentes d'abord aussi été à
la fois matheux physiciens ingénieurs
philosophe tout ce qu'on veut et puis il
travaille sur tous les sujets et puis il
était assez confuse il sauté bien à
l'autre il faudrait que le film soit un
peu confus et thierry le physicien toi
comment tu te sens par rapport à
poincaré le physicien ses clients
mythique effectivement ça
les derniers grands personnages qui
faisaient des physiques à très haut
niveau de la baptême des mathématiques
autre niveau qui pouvait prendre parti
sur des problèmes philosophiques ou
droits de l'homme dont on parlera
j'imagine donc ça c'est un petit peu une
une image qu on aimerait ressembler un
petit peu albert tout raconte nous ton
bras pour un team d'abord et pour calais
prague à raymond et au fait que je te
paie ty dillon et après je crois qu'il
est ma vie ma thématique chaque jour
j'utilise century munis des quelque
chose et pas failli
c'est y pas que c'est facile à faire un
film de lui parce qu'il est tellement
les choses ça par glen pearson a dit
dans un coma
c'est pas facile non c'est pas un seul
mais fait peur il me fait plus mais une
personnalité incroyable et je suppose qu
alain catoire vous demande à quoi ça
sert les mathématiques qu'est ce que
vous répondez
qu'est ce que je peux vous dire j'écris
je suis je dit le but de la recherche
scientifique ne doit pas être de
diminuer des souffrances humaines car
pour diminuer les surfaces humaine il
suffirait tout simplement de détruire
d'humanité diminuer les souffrances
humaines est un but négatif nous devons
poursuivre la recherche de la vérité
voilà ce que chic la recherche de la
vérité et vous avez ajouté doit être le
but de notre activité
si le seul objectif qui en soit digne le
seul but de notre arrivée c'est ça que
j'écris exactement
merci de me le rappeler
[Rires]
regarde la bayard un arbre mort qui est
bon c'est à bord et ressemble à un arbre
mathématiques qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
arbre mathématiques alberto n'y a pas de
boucles alors on va les voir et à cet
arbre mort je filme alberto voyant un
arbre mort
ouais c'est mathématique
c'est un arbre qui n'est pas tout à fait
mathématique pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
aient pas mathématique et les arbres
mathématiques sont pas gros mais non
enfin les lignes
ah bon j'ai vu un beau triangle quelque
part moi oui on va faire un atout mais
alberto on va dessiner des triangles sur
la mémoire des mots je vais tracés à la
craie le remettre le point à le pointer
le point c'est parra qui a fait une
bifurcation vote tourne à gauche voilà
assez voilà et maintenant on va faire le
troisième côté du triangle
je vous fais c
et où alors bon triangle bce y voilà
alors qu'est-ce qu'a 2 intéressant dans
ce triangle on voit que les côtés ici
bcbg ab en fait ils sont presque pareil
il dit le triangle f1 mais ça veut dire
que la géométrie sur cet arbre et non ne
chrétienne d'où cette idée de l'arbre
qui illustre la géométrie non
euclidienne moi ça m'a beaucoup inspiré
quoi quand roman phare iv nous dit voilà
il est sain sur des arbres et ça donne
une intuition de ce à quoi il faut
penser pour la géométrie mais méridienne
moi je trouve fallu trouver ça très
éclairant oui effectivement cet arbre
qu'on voit là c'est c'est une version du
disque de poincaré
ça me plaît bien cette image
carrez a expliqué longuement parce que
les gens qui sont autour de lui dit mais
c'est là qu'elle qui est vrai est ce que
la géométrie euclidienne elle est vraie
ou est ce que c'est la géométrie non
euclidienne crif qui est vrai laquelle
des deux vrais et là cette phrase
magnifique il dit et je vous raconterai
cette question n'a pas de sens certaines
géométrie sont plus commode que d'autres
dans certaines situations mais qu'est ce
que c'est que mon nom ne régale
par exemple lorsqu'on se déplace d'un
endroit en france un autre endroit ce
qui compte
en face qui nous intéresse n'est pas
tellement la distance au sens
géographique ce mais c'est le temps
qu'il faut alors on est on à faire une
géométrie qui n'est pas du tout l'idée
un second il faut passer par paris au
lieu de valeo ou djce en droit et cela
déforme un peu conceptuellement mais
aussi jugés racistes pratiquement la
carte de la france est produit quelque
chose qui est tout à fait non nucléaires
est ce que c'est vraiment important pour
les événements tous les jours pour la
vie réelle pour le félicia que je suis
justement je pense que on peut prendre
le mans dire que c'est la contribution
de margaret quoi nous explique c'est
vraiment une géométrique est
omniprésente et utile utile en maths
mais également à l'extérieur de maths en
physique et puis
je dirais même en philosophie c'est à
dire c'est une façon de se libérer
vraiment devoir libérer du carcan de la
géométrie euclidienne ça engendrait une
liberté dans le monde artistique par
exemple tout à coup les artistes se sont
rendu compte qu'il n'était plus obligé
de ceux de se limiter à ce qu'on
apprenait dans les cours de perspectives
dans l'école des beaux arts
tout à coup ils se sont libérés des
contraintes de la géométrie euclidienne
étape-clé coffrage et poincaré
comme disait etienne c'est vraiment de
la liberté qu'ils donnent aux gens de
penser à des jioi très différentes voire
une infinité de géométrie des yeux aussi
qu'on rentre les autres par exemple si
on peut utiliser la géométrie dans des
problèmes vie biologique
on sonne à l'entendre comme ça on a
l'impression que c'est c'est une
hallucination
mais ce qu'on entend par là c'est que
j'ai beaucoup de problèmes par exemple
biologie de physique de des applications
diverses peuvent être commis région ré
interpréter comme des problèmes de
géométrie
or s'ils n'y a qu'une seule géométrie
enfin des possibilités d'interprétation
comme ça sont très limités mais s'il ya
beaucoup de géométrie à notre
disposition et bien et de plus des yeux
mais très flexible alors on peut d
interpréter ont peu déserté a énormément
énormément de situations pratiques
cette géométrie non euclidienne apparaît
partout dans des structures
arborescentes ou quand on regarde le
développement d'une feuille
où la plupart des développements qui se
font par des mécanismes locaux cellules
qui se développe souvent tendance à
prendre une géométrie qui est dans le
cri diène
[Musique]
on
et c'est un livre que je trouve vraiment
remarquable parce que la préface est
très général et elle expose les
différentes théories dont on disposait à
l'époque pour expliquer l'origine du
système solaire nous ne pouvons donc
terminer que par un point
d'interrogation
autrement dit il explique que c'est un
sujet passionnant c'est un sujet sur
lequel ben on ne sait pas grand chose
mais c'est pas parce qu'on sait rien
qu'il faut pas en parler mais moi ce que
je vous propose c'est que l'un d'entre
nous se transforme en point que réalise
la première page le problème de
l'origine du monde a de tout temps
préoccuper tous les hommes qui
réfléchissent
il est impossible de contempler le
spectacle de l'univers étoiles et sans
se demander comment il s'est formé nous
devrions peut-être attendre pour
chercher une solution que nous en ayons
patiemment rassemblé les éléments et que
nous ayons acquis par là quelques
espoirs sérieux de la trouver mais si
nous étions si raisonnable si nous
étions curieux sans impatience
il est probable que nous n'aurions
jamais créé la science et que nous nous
serions toujours contenté de vivre notre
petite vie c'est super c'est curieux
sans impatience le système solaire nous
présente le spectacle une parfaite
harmonie les orbites des planètes sont
presque toute circulaire tout à peu près
dans un même plan toutes parcouru dans
le même sens ce n'est peut-être l'effet
du hasard
certes il y encore bien des gens qui ken
ham dieu créateur pour une hypothèse
nécessaire mais le conçoivent plus
l'intervention divine comme le faisait
lors devanciers lors du et moi
architectes et plus mécaniciens et il
reste alors à expliquer par quel
mécanisme il a tiré l'ordre du chaos
ça pose le problème opposé à ce qu'on
disait hier on disait que les lois de la
nature faisait convergé vers la mort que
tu sens une l'ordre disparaît c'est la
folie uniforme on arrivait dans une
soupe uniforme et lapointe grain dit
comment ça se fait que alors évidemment
si c'était la solaire doit évidemment
c'est pas contradictoire parce que comme
ça une expansion globale tu peux voir un
mouvement global de dalles et de très
grande échelle de l'association moins
ordonnée mais pas d'échelle ce n'est que
ça requiert une explication
qu'est ce qui se passe pour que ce qui
m'a frappé dans cette préface celle que
si des particules un grand nombre
s'entrechoquer continuer on tend vers
cette soupe cette pagaille uniforme
mercredi justement qu'en fait et je ne
sais pas jusqu'à quel point on peut
pousser ce point que en fait ce qui crée
l'ordre commencent à créer d'ordre c'est
la perte d'énergie c'est la dissipation
c'est le frottement
c'est à dire que si chaplin collision
est complètement au hasard et il n'y a
pas de perte d'énergie ça continue ça
continue avec la même commune irais je
énergie et bien ça va tendre vers le
chaos
mais la viscosité c'est que il ya deux
choses qui se rencontrent et en fait à
la limite de traîtres et visqueuse à la
limite le frottement des deux sukhoï et
la forme quelque chose d'un peu plus
grand une autre chose ce code est ainsi
de suite et ça commence à créer une
structure quand même expliquer ce que
pointe et rex tout dans ce livre c'est
donc la théorie de la place selon
laquelle
le système solaire commence par une
énorme boule de gaz
quand on dit gaz s'est pas vraiment à
gaz c'est une collection d'objets
célestes et qui tournent à vitesse
lentement à vitesse constante et donc
dès l'âge de 24 ans est question d masri
de rotation la lah préoccupés devant ses
actionnaires dieu fait le dessin suivant
une terre fluide hypothétique
maintenant je me comment ça va faire
tourner lentement très longue ça va se
dilater du côté de l'équateur
ça va se contracter du côté du pôle nord
et on peut imaginer que la courbe qui
dissipe peut-être une ellipse parfaite
celle à l'ellipse aux ide de révolution
pourront d'une rotation ça marche si la
vitesse de rotation que notre oméga est
assez petit
c'est ce qui se passe pour notre terre
la terre tourne assez lentement
jacoby a démontré que quand le truc se
met à tourner tourner tourner il ya un
moment où c'est ellipsoïde qui est
parfaitement rond au niveau de
l'équateur père sarthe entités et
devient une ellipse au niveau de
l'équateur et ce qu'a démontré point que
c'est que quand on prend le leap solide
de jacoby avec les trois axes différents
et on continue à faire tourner plus vite
plus de plus de 8
il arrive un moment où les lips torride
perd sa stabilité
il a trouvé une forme extrêmement
étonnante ça à venir
menhir de révolution est prêt à
démontrer que cet objet existe c'est la
première fois que on dit on parle de
provocation d'un phénomène qui dit
quelque chose comme a fait de même que
j'oserais appelé bifurcation notation et
maintenat et essayer dans tous les sens
je peux proposer un excellent exemple
d'une location ou non une feuille de
papier et j'appuie sur les deux or comme
ça un moment donné si je continue à
augmenter
l'aps est la pression ça c'est des
formes et ça s'appelle le flambage à
propos off et c'est une bifurcation d'un
régime un autre est la même chose si je
mets une bille ici au fond de la vallée
c'est une petite vallée et la billette
au fond ne sais pas qui a une autre
vallée à côté qui est plus basse et la
bia est tranquillement au fond de sa
petite vallée tranquillement stable et
puis s'il ya une érosion progressive qui
va éroder progressivement les râles et
là et toujours au fonds de cinq chefs
vallée et puis ça se passe tout
tranquille 20 et puis un jour la vallée
de la montagne ici la colline ici a été
érodée et ce jour là la vie tout à coup
se rend compte qu'elle peut tomber et
qu'une call aura beaucoup de davantage à
temps et elle tombe tout à coup
donc le phénomène de l'érosion est un
phénomène continue l'an progressif et
pourtant la bille qui est ici est
tranquillement au fond de sa vallée un
jour elle tombe donc l'observateur
extérieur il voit rien elle voit rien et
tout à coup part c'est ce qu'on appelle
une bifurcation
leur signification scène d'euthanasie ou
celle ci en beaucoup de l'exemple en
physique on parle d'universalité
on peut regrouper selon ces suppressions
énormément de phénomènes physiques
cette forme est très intéressante longue
et si on voit comme ça c'est comme si
c'était une forme des ongles l'epso
wydad
mais terry infi mois dessus mais tout
doucement et continua à pied de plus en
plus et là tout d'un coup de façon
discontinue s'est passé à une autre
solution si vous voulez et c'est comme
si on passait l'ellipse dignité du stade
et c'est cette forme qui est devenu
stable
on passe d'une vallée à une autre valeur
et ça à une application pratique parce
que il suffit de faire ici
pour résumer c'est quand même point
qu'il ya les gars j'ai ce concept
il a dégagé ce concept sur l'exemple des
masques et d'invocation que ce soit sur
le génial c'est que sur un exemple
extrêmement concret pratique physique
pertinent et impertinent il a réussi à
dégager le l'idée générale de
bifurcation carrément envahi toute la
physique mais aussi toutes les matches
donc c'est intéressant tels que le
mathématicien que tu ai dit qu'il faut
c'est merveilleux d'avoir commencé ses
rangs problème pertinents donc oui
physiquement pertinents celle non mais
c'est vrai ça d'abord ça le ça rend le
problème encore plus beau
[Musique]
diffusion security
turenne qui est le premier a compris la
stabilité c'est un exemple où tu veux
puisqu'un téléphone la vie qui va
permettre d'avoir il à paris surfent à
terme
[Musique]
donc à ce moment je quittais camp où
j'habitais alors pour prendre part à une
course géologique entreprises par
l'école des mines
les péripéties du voyage me faire
oublier mes travaux mathématiques arrivé
à coutances montanes dans un omnibus
pour je ne sais quel promenade au moment
où je mettais le pied sur le marche pied
l'idée me vingt sans que rien dans mes
pensées l'intérieur paru mi avoir
préparé l'idée me vint que les
transformations dont j'avais fait usage
pour définir les fonctions fixe yen et
est identique à celle de la géométrie
non euclidienne mais j'ai tout de suite
une entière certitude de retour à caen
je vérifiais le résultat à tête reposée
pour laquelle ma conscience donc ça
c'est un épisode célèbre qu'elle ait
connu là le moment où poincaré marche
sur sa nation sur la marge du tramway et
hop l'idée jaillit mais quelque chose
qui ressort vont très très clairement
dans ce texte rousset le qu'on appelle
parfois le nez au plateau 10 le
néoplatonisme jeu pac man il faut dire
des mathématiciens qui est vraiment
l'idée que le mathématicien se promène
dans un monde d'idées qui que ces dits d
exister indépendamment de vous les
il le dit très explicitement que c'est
un voyage et d'effets de d'explorateurs
dans un champ à découvrir bon vraiment
la plupart des mathématiciens pense
comme ça c'est 90% des de nos collègues
ou là tu crois je pensais majorité à moi
je crois que ça évolue
je pense que c'est heureux ça revient en
force mais je pense que un petit sondage
express est ce que tu as l'impression
qu'on découvre au concret des
mathématiques on découvre on découvre
moi aussi mais enfin quand bien même
s'il ya des logiciens des penseurs tout
hacker c'est de me convaincre du
contraire et qui ont peut-être raison
je pense que c'est la seule ma seule
façon de vivre les maths c'est de faire
comme si je découvrais
oui et non sinon je voudrais beaucoup
moins de plaisir en faire je suis assez
d'accord avec le fait que c'est
difficile en tant que magicien de dans
la pratique de pas de pas avoir
l'impression de découvrir mais mais mais
en fait ce dont j'ai l'impression que
j'aimerais dire qu'on découvre une
construction qui nous est commune
élevé dans ce sens là je pense que j'ai
pas besoin de me raccrocher à un univers
platonicien de l'existence d'objets
mathématiques au quotidien à côté de
travail
est ce que tu es pas vraiment en train
d'essayer de déterrer les objets qui
sont des gens qui sont enterrés dans mon
quotidien
encore une fois je pense qu'on crée ont
créé ces objets comme notre cerveau qui
ce que le cerveau crée ces objets et
card est qui et qui regroupe tu es seul
contre tous c'est une position j'aime
bien non mais je pense que par cédric il
et je sais pas s'il est celui qui a la
meilleure réponse mais une chose est
sûre c'est que dans tous les exposés que
tu fais de vendée prend publics etc
cette question est ce que vous découvrez
que vous inventez elle est absolument
permanente revient toujours toujours
toujours toujours y avait quelque chose
qui interpelle la presse que je ce que
je réponds c'est que on peut débattre
que c'est une question de religion parce
qu'on peut vraiment sur une croyance un
tig ou pas vraiment prouver mais j'aime
bien rappeler que là c'est pas seulement
un débat philosophique ou sur le sexe
des anges ou qui sait quoi ça va plus
sur notre façon de travailler quand
ombre quand on travaille en étant
persuadé qu'on découvre on va chercher
le miracle
consciemment ou inconsciemment on va
chercher un truc qui l'attend dit quand
on travaille on croyait qu'on crée on se
demande comment je fais comment
j'appréhende le truc c'est pas la même
sont pas les mêmes réflexes 7 il ya
aussi cette question que poincaré à bord
de cette flash killer queen pied sur le
est-ce que vous avez eu des expériences
analogues
absolument les russes lâchent tout ce
cirque flash et à lire le lien avec une
certitude
voilà absolue avec une butée et aussi
qui on l année là les conditions
prescrites déjà eu un flash d'une
certitude
et puis après bien sûr oui bien sûr on a
quand même ce cette certitude peut
arriver surtout lorsqu'on travaille de
manière un peu théorique et qu'on n'est
pas trop proche des expériences ça
arrive ce que j'aime beaucoup dans le
texte c'est l'alternance entre démarche
consciente et les marches inconsciente
qui est très très très vraie celle qui
était la plus marquante peut-être harris
avis et c'est un pour le coup j'étais en
calcul il s'agissait de trouver le bon
la bonne méthode pour la bonne manière
de faire le calcul
et après une nuit saccagés par des
tentatives qui n'aboutissaient pas non
mais j'ai dormi j'ai dormi quelques
heures et au réveil et je vous jure au
réveil il ya une voix qui me parle dans
ma tête et qui me disait comment il
fallait faire c'était sa chute et tu
prends la tension de fourier tu fait de
passer l'autre côté tu inverses pas
niveau qui te disais et buttes les
anglais hors de france
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
on
et
bon
[Musique]
je
la faute ou venez pas les musiciens de
moore est soldée avec tous les
graphismes de lettonie maris chien marie
curie dé l'oréal à adaisseh n'y trouve
alaia il ya une ferrari une fille parmi
combien un peu plus que dormir un peu
plus que parfait c'est mieux que parmi
nous et c'était quand même un set qui se
trouvait solo d une année avant qui
rappelle moi donc la mécanique quantique
commencé à exister mécanique froide il
tg restreint 1905
donc au niveau de la mécanique quantique
c'est vraiment réservé donc c'est
l'époque des points quantiques presqu'un
ses terres et la justice photos à ma
chambre
[Musique]
où
henri poincaré fait peu de politique
mais ce qu'il a fait ici la cendre et
puces il s'est impliqué dans la sphère
de réussite assez fortement
mais en tant que scientifique enfin en
tant que militant politique en tant que
mathématicien à titre personnel oui des
collègues là l'hiver il va vraiment
témoigner mais vraiment toujours en
gardant cette idée de le scientifique
c'est à dire ils témoignent pas sûr sur
l'ambiance générale etc
il est là sur la méthode comment est-ce
que ça intéressant de ce point de vue là
c'est une sorte de création de police
scientifique c'est ça coïncide à cette
région c'est sa conclusion est que c'est
du pipeau pipeau et là et là ça
participe certainement pour beaucoup à
la réhabilitation de dreyfus est une
bonne question c'est la police
scientifique est belle établi maintenant
mais est-ce que les mathématiciens et 12
vraiment ce rôle là mattia les
physiciens les scientifiques jouent
vraiment ce rôle politique qu'ils
avaient au début du 20e siècle tout
finalement assez peu pourquoi ne sont
peut-être pas entendu parler politique
ou d'être peut-être que c'est nous mêmes
qui nous impliquons trotter grande
hêtraie a brillé dans la filière
un parti communiste
il a plein d'aujourd'hui il faut bien
reconnaître que c'est michel
les statistiques sont plus vraiment des
intellectuels comme il était à l'époque
engagé ce qu'on passe trop de temps avec
les approches je laisserai une
explication c'est que la politique dans
les années 60 70
c'est quelque chose d'assez qui voilà ce
trait comme quelque chose de quelque
chose enfin de l'important c'est à dire
il ya déjà là même le marxisme c'est une
théorie que j'ai quand même qui résonne
bien avec les maths qui est assez
abstraite et puis il ya tous mouvements
structuraliste la f1 la gaule à gauche
des années 60 70 et est assez abstraite
et je pense que cela résonne dit ça
rentre bien résonance avec avec les
mathématiques et maintenant balleux
imprime jusqu'à gagner politiquement et
même dans le militantisme débauche c'est
que c'est beaucoup plus pragmatisme et
brave pragmatique et c est peut-être que
c'est pas sans lien avec avec le fait
que l'engagement de mathématiciens et
des effets blier beaucoup
[Musique]
le coupé des melons que j'ai pu compter
le nombre de semaines d'arrêt du buzz et
bien j'ai connu comme étant d'intérêt
s'est toujours voulu souligner le dr
voudra pas oublier de sitôt
comment est ce qu'on peut construire
imaginez des espèces dimension 3 eh ben
on pense déjà un espace à deux
dimensions par exemple à la surface de
la terre ou la surface ben du gwenn
carrément et on les paie si un tipi
bassam on constate c'est que le bord
d'un côté ressemble au bord de l'autre
côté le voir des deux couches donc il ya
un moyen d'identifier ces de retenue
mais bon on va dire que quand on arrive
par à côté on repart on rentre travaux
ministère et dans la manière de recoller
la face b you avec l'adresse et et
jusqu'à présent on avait des moyens
d'essayer de voir que deux espaces
étaient pas les mêmes mais c'étaient des
moyens rudimentaires et ce qu'a proposé
point par point car et c'est une
nouvelle façon de distinguer ces espaces
il a c'est évident que ces deux espaces
sont pas les mêmes la surface du melon à
la surface de du temps mais là alberto
est un moyen de le montrer c'est à dire
qu'ici on nous un petit là c'est sûr
fait une petite courbe qui se ferme sur
le melon et qu'on est on peut toujours
la déformer les toits et thuram
ratatiner en un point alors que sur le
tort si on prend une petite courbe qui
fait le tour
comme ça on pourra jamais on a bola
bouger dans tous les sens on n'arrive
pas à la ratatiner en un point vous
voilà vraiment ce qu'ils disent
le tort du melon donc ça c'est une idée
qui paraît un petit peu bête sur ces
phases-là mais qui est fondamental parce
que cette idée en quarts et montre on
peut la développer dans des espaces bien
plus compliquée qu'on n'arrive même pas
à dessiner qu'on arrive face à se
présenter c'est vraiment complète de
poincaré
il ya inventer des outils comme ce que
viennent nous explique nicolas avec des
lacets et c'est pour rendre cette étude
purement qualitative en études quand tu
étais un quantitative est tellement
quantitatif qu'elle est algébrique c'est
pour ça qu'on dit on dit en général aux
points d'arrêt est le fondateur la
topologie algébrique
[Musique]
je vais courbet ce papier on est ce
qu'on va se dire et j'ai fixé la forme
avec l'aide de deux points ici et ici
maintenant qu'est ce qui va se passer si
je me mets à tirer les deux bouts du
papier eh bien vous voir les deux
trombones août se rapproche de plus en
plus si je contiens attirer davantage
pour ça saute
thierry m'ont pas tout le monde ils se
sont enlacés
alors ça c'était la version 2 0 des
siens primitive maintenant je voudrais
vous montrer quelques variantes qui vont
nous mener à la topologie
je prépare exactement la même
configuration que tout à l'heure mais
cette fois ci j'ai ajouté un élastique
il est double boucle ici ici ce qui
arrive c'est fixe aussi élastique
restituer le poker est tombé dans le
gain est appréciable mais plus j'en ai
ramassé le trouble
une troisième expérience à faire c'est
de +2 alors c'est comme ça parce que sa
c2 et tourner derrière vous et que c'est
une autre copie de deux bons qu'est ce
qui va se passer maintenant tout va
ajouter de la combe et c'est ce que j'ai
passé lorsque j'ai découvert cette manif
cette fois-ci toutefois tout reste sur
le papier donc c'est élastique n'est pas
du tout liés au papier mais il y ait
seulement grâce à l'autre et dasté de
même si on faisait disparaître cette
élastique transversale de lastminute
ombre et donc on considère que le papier
et le dernier élastique derniers siècles
nous ont mis six ans un système de trois
cercles qui ne sont pas 2 à 2 enlacés
mais trois ensemble ils sont coincés et
ça s'appelle l'entrelacs pour mes seins
qui se présente comme ça
c'est un objet vous vrai que si je fais
disparaître ce bois nous boude voix qui
je tiens les deux autres peuvent se
détacher de même de même être un peu de
notre partir comme un tripode est maître
par exemple quelque chose
[Musique]
où
ces compressions à faire on va on va
mettre tout dans une position presque
assez régulière on va lancer billes
blanches
ça va faire un peu le chaos et on va
raconter combien de be2 il ya dans par
chaque branche et puis enfin deuxième
fois ce sera différent on va voir si
c'est les mêmes répartition yahoo va on
peut faire plusieurs l'expérience ans en
parallèle on peut aussi regarder à
chaque fois que les positions finales
les beaux-arts une boule marqué là c'est
à dire ses côtés de léo ferré de la fois
une part lancions en longueur quant à la
gauche et à droite et au regard doux et
la police et ma fenêtre
néanmoins le palace et de tableau mais
je vais te les viroulais de vie dure
cette étude est trop vision de la
gestion mais trois droite ou gauche
allez c'est pas mal ça n'a pas bougé
2 3 4 5 et 6 6 6 du côté droit
elle impressionne à vouloir de caunes a
dit qu'elle était à droite disons 4
voilà les temps et des moyens
/ je te paie des pistes et marion
quintinaise la photo mais on ne fait pas
ça j'en veux dire c'est trop mon nom le
résumé c'est que même si la tâche y
envoient presque toujours la même boule
blanche
j'ai presque toujours le même triangle
ça va dans tous les sens et complètement
chaotique
une petite modification de la cause peut
avoir des grandes conséquences sur les
effets c'est une première chose c'est ce
qu'on appelle la dépendance sensible aux
conditions initiales mais ça ça n'est
qu'une seule chose la chose qui est
beaucoup plus importante est ce qu on a
plus ou moins constaté l'ats c'est que
même si la répartition exacte des billes
de billard après qu'on ait frappé des
temps de conditions initiales ça fait
changer complètement
il n'empêche que quand on regarde ce qui
se passe après un certain temps la
statistique est absolument insensible
aux conditions initiales et c'est ce
fait qui est vraiment un fait positif
alors c'est vrai pour ces connu pour le
billard mais c'est probablement connu
pour plein d'autres systèmes physiques
comme
très peu de systèmes par exemple si on
veut penser que c'est une bille de
billard est une molécule dans
l'atmosphère qui se baladent si au lieu
de penser que les mollets que se taper
élastique mans elle se tape
interagissent entre elles dans l'espace
alors là on sait rien non mais elle vous
raconte l importante souvent honni le
système est chaotique
donc on peut pas faire de prédictions
mais au contraire on a vu que du dollar
si on pas le moyenne statistique on
préférerait seulement on a une bonne
très bonne information à la fin
justement parce que le système est
fréquent mais ça c'est un moral aussi
général qui sous tend toute la théorie
classique des probabilités
puis c'est aléatoire au niveau d'une
expérience individuelle et plus ils
étaient amis nistos niveau de
statistiques
[Musique]
quand on parle de poincaré fondateur de
la théorie route des lacs systèmes
dynamiques etc
je pensais que ce serait se serait pas
bien de réduire au chaos et au système
chaotique ce n'était pas du tout
chaotique au début de la carrière de
poincaré il a il a commencé en 1895 donc
vraiment très jeune a à faire ce qu'on
appelle à théorie qualitative les six
cliniques et chose comme ça pour te
donner des exemples de ce type les
limites simplement du jeu en partie où
les vents dû le forcer
je vais choisir un exemple pour
reprendre dans un champ il ya des lapins
et des rumeurs si il n'y a pas du tout
de renard c'est à dire que 0 et disons
qu'il est beaucoup d'herbe ou dans le
champ si il est un certain nombre de
lapins et bien vivant par augmenter
parce que des lapins ce qu'on se
produire je ne vais pas expliquer son
côté de la question vous êtes tous se
trouve très grande
donc ça va remonter ça va alors on peut
commencer avec un certain nombre de
renards mais ils seront affamés et vous
mourir et de nombreux blessés
et ça va tomber vers euros mais qu'est
ce qui va se passer si on a un certain
nombre lapin et un certain nombre de
renards
ici par exemple le nombre de la femme
commence à augmenter le nombre n'a aussi
nos collègues honnart de la page de
l'ère nos filles montent mais renards
sont contents parce que la main n'a pas
augmenté mais là ici les renards
commencent à augmenter et le renard sont
trop nombreux donc
rapin essaie de manger de l'herbe et des
cèdres se multiplient mais ils ne vont
pas assez vite dans que les renards ont
mangé trop de latin ne va pas commencer
à diminuer c'est à dire que ça va dans
ce sens mais nous raconte première
moitié mais des renards ont été trop
loin phr et ils ont mangé trop de la
panne donc il y à passer de la terre
pour nourrir tous les maires dont le
nombre de vols a prononcé à tomber mais
si le nombre de renards suffisamment de
la panne ne sont plus menacés donc ils
peuvent commencer à augmenter ainsi chic
donc ça va
dans une orbite périple en quantité
importante dans le lait ça que tu fais
que le physicien beaucoup c'est la
notion de période
il va falloir un certain temps de faire
le tour mais c'est vrai la notion de
période est ce qu'on voit c'est que si
un certain moment ce point là il ya une
tornade ou des maladies qui diminue le
nombre de renards très rapidement à
cause de la foudre qui tu dis renard on
va tomber ici et très vite on va revenir
sur la même courbe et donc on va avoir
une évolution avec la même période
voilà donc ça c'est un point très fort
de la cites les limites et qu'il ya
beaucoup d'exemples en biologie par donc
l'évolution de la période des vibrations
des neurones on a des neurones qui
normalement vivre à certaines pulsations
une certaine période
ils sont synchronisées très rapidement
et donc sur les perturbe ou si on va par
exemple on prend l'avion on habituel
affaires de 24 heures à partir de
quelques jours au cerey costabelli sur
une période bien précise
sauf que sauf que sauf que
ça se passe en dimensions 2 et beaucoup
de personnes ont un peu exagéré ce
modèle qui fonctionne quand dimensions
2d qu'on passe un dimension supérieure
il n'est pas rare qu'on rencontre des
situations chaotiques comme comme le dia
est donc tout le taux de travail du
mathématicien consiste précisément le
physicien d'ailleurs qu'en 6 à trouver
la part des choses entre annuellement
aux périodiques ou chaotiques de tout
problème c'est de faire la part des
choses entre pour faire chier qu'on dit
entre l'harmonie et le chaos
ce qui a popularisé vraiment le cas aux
l'effet papillon c'est la découverte de
lawrence attracteurs étranges le fait
que quand on prend un mini mini modèles
réduits météo avec juste trois degrés de
liberté on obtient un comportement très
difficiles à prévoir et implicitement il
y avait l'idée si avec 3 degrés liberté
déjà on a ça alors que dire quand on a
le vrai système complet mais si ça se
trouve justement c'est parce qu'on a
gardé que trois degrés de liberté que ça
devient imprévisible et qui est ce qui
est plus courant
le gao ou ou le régulier c'est vraiment
un enjeu majeur aujourd'hui quoi est ce
que est ce que plus souvent il faut
s'attendre à des choses chaotique
on a vu souvent les joueuses régulières
je pense que tadashi a certainement
raison pour une raison très simple c'est
que pendant des siècles on n'a jamais eu
le cas et si on n'a pas vu c'est
peut-être que il n'est pas si fréquent
plein
[Musique]
toute ta vie jeux mathématiques voilà
c'est un problème mathématique tonnes
d'or nous avons un séjour tout alors 1 2
trèfles ici voilà ici
2 le 13 conditions de cette offre là ça
c'est du concret pur cru
c'est un sujet d'actualité un croyant je
sais plus cru avec potter bon ton rêve
ce sens c'est bon récit bien génial tu
veux en tout cas de figure oui ça c'est
un portrait des magazines et alberto pas
picasso c'est plus compenser
efficacement fois
[Musique]
et
tous
oh
cité
[Musique]
là
e
m
à
[Musique]